hey everybody welcome back to this week
in startups I'm your host Jason
Calacanis you can follow me
instagram.com slash Jason and you will
see pictures and stories about my kids
and whatever meet I am grilling that's
that's it you also see sometimes some
traveling and some FOMA stuff but rest
assured all of the FOMA traveling posts
those are all photoshopped by my team
and they just put that up there to be
bidden to know we're interesting ever
know this is my new thing I just I'm
having my team Photoshop me yeah
whatever the like greatest event is so
when Coachella is going on you're like
they're running the rules in Italy
Burning Man
they just Photoshop me into those and
then we post them and then we post a
private jet in between which I don't
have of course you have one now I sold
the company and then we just let people
wonder how I'm able to live this
lifestyle and be so productive fabulous
my guest today
Samir Dholakia don't like still nailing
it or lochia is it a Indian or Pakistani
Indian it's India born and raised in
Mumbai India
you're kidding yeah wow these career
named ago immigrated to the states in
the 60s and so that's where my brother
and I were born and raised really we're
just outside of Boston Massachusetts Wow
yeah it was that rough well I say rough
only because you know there was a Boston
drop yeah there was no area there
weren't a lot of Indian families around
let's put it that way yeah just do it
out a little
and those Bostonian unique yeah
butterflies you're just so graceful your
point of being graceful and gentle yes
yeah they're very welcoming of new
newcomers absolutely I joke about that
Nike I should say in all in all
sincerity our particular neighborhood
was amazing and our neighbors were
awesome and they were very welcoming
yeah the broader community around us the
town at large yeah a little bit
different I was the brown the where's
the brown kid at one little head Little
League tryouts oh yes great it was
different it was a different moment in
time now so drew you're you're crushing
it do you buy into this I think a lot of
my Indian friends will call it the curry
ceiling
are you aware of this no never heard
that yeah it's a Curie ceiling yeah not
Steph Curry but I'd like the curb like
curry so they would call it that in the
90s there was a belief in Silicon Valley
yeah that Indians could ascend to you
know really high positions yeah VP SVP
yeah but no team not samaya yeah did you
experience that coming up we did you
feel like maybe I didn't I was very
fortunate you know Sanger is my my
second CEO job my first one I had 10 10
or 11 years ago now and so I was
fortunate that I didn't experience that
but I think times are changing I think
it helps that right now I was funny I
was in to fun trips I was in Italy over
the summer with my family on vacation
and I was in this at this resort and
there was an investor that was hanging
out in the pool and you know you start
chit-chatting Americans and foreign
players start talking and he says you
know I really hope I'm waiting for an
Indian to take over Facebook because it
worked out really well when Microsoft
went sundar took over Google and Simon
satya took over Microsoft and say
waiting for that and I just like I had
to laugh that's all I should think sucks
doing all right but I understand you do
well actually back to your Wow we found
somebody that's in the favor of sucks
unique but your point of management
style yeah if you were gonna pick a
value yeah move fast and break things
where would that be on your list it's
important to be on the list
I think progress over perfection is is
something we talked a lot about it at
the joint company Twilio center being
nimble be nimble yeah those matter you
know I would say we often start from a
we not I had set teams do great things
is humility first where customer centric
you know we're here to serve our
customers a bull in a china shop not
done it's probably not as prominent as
the we serve we are here to serve our
customers it was such a great when you
think about it though in retrospect move
fast and break things just gave
everybody permission with just that one
value yeah
tonigh
care about mistakes which you know if
you break some who cares so you can
broken who cares yeah however that
served them so well on the way up and so
poorly at scale it's I think it's a very
interesting point yeah there's a time
and place for things and you're
absolutely like you drove a probably a
set of innovations where small teams are
moving at speed and and that can be
awesome and as you are at scale it can
it can be a little bit more dangerous
and you gotta like taking rubles for
racist ads against Hillary Clinton yeah
and I would be there or not yeah yeah I
mean they literally spend more time I
think on keeping competitors off the
platform than they did looking at
advertisers like why would we put any
the cycles on slowing down people
spending money right let's just kill all
our competitors by see I mean I saw that
VPN thing they were doing studying no
although they basically bought a company
on vo or something was Israeli company
that would be a VPN hmm then they used
the VPN they bought the company because
the VPN was on so many phones that they
knew exactly the utilization of snapchat
what's a et cetera so then they had the
inside information of which apps to kill
which ones to buy yeah which you know
yeah it was pretty nefarious craziness
speaking which how do you deal with that
because I know that was a MailChimp
issue too in the beginning days email is
used for a lot of nefarious spear
fishing fishing craziness yeah obviously
yeah how do you when you're giving away
the first free ten thousand yeah emails
for free like it's not one of the core
offerings just to get the first 10,000
yes a day free how do you mitigate
against Russian hackers spamming and all
that and how often are you attacked yeah
unfortunately all the time and I would
say it's it's one of the reasons I
believe Sanger has been so successful is
we even we've invested over the past
literally decade tons of both process
and engineering to defense systems and
and I think we built a brand and a
reputation in the industry we we
actually will fire lots and lots of
customers new signups that we do not
believe are sending wanted mail like
that's our catchphrase like we only want
to deliver wanted mail wanted mail means
the recipient asked to get it and
they're happy to be receiving it like
the open rates on our platform like we
send just by the way just as a sense of
scale I think we sent something on the
order of I gotta go the last public
number was north of 40 billion emails in
a month over a billion emails every
single day our open rates are north of
20 percent that's a lot that's pretty
great that's pretty pretty means
retailers are getting five ten percent
open rates by three to five that yeah
they'd be doing cartwheels yeah
so it we send wanted mail and we take we
pride ourselves on that but we had to go
build machine learning systems to go vet
site people that are coming in to sign
up and we would check a bunch of
different variables and figure out does
this look like legit then we would we
would we check okay how we're only gonna
let them send a little bit and then
we're gonna go watch the engagement
rates with their subscribers and we will
open the funnel or the pipe yep if it's
looking good and if it's looking really
bad and people are getting flagged as
spam we shut it down what when I hit
spam in Gmail or if somebody hits it in
there whatever mail client they're using
Yahoo whatever does that data get back
to you somehow is there a protocol and
what is that protocol how does it work
yeah we actually partnered closely with
with Google and then later Yahoo and
other ISPs inbox service providers to
create something we call the FBL the
feedback loop and we literally said we
all in this ecosystem have a aligned
incentive to want to keep the bad actors
out nobody wants the spear phishing
email you know grandma's being taken
advantage of
you know spam flooding our inbox you
can't actually get to there the right
one so we have a lot of data about who's
who looks like a bad actor you all have
a lot of big data on who looks like a
bad actor let's create a feedback loop
both ways and so we started that and
then because you know you're trying to
do the right thing we're like you know
what we should open this up to other
esps email service providers that
compete with Sigrid and the ISPs you
know now provide that out to all the
ESPs but I think it's helped immensely
to cut down on spam and fish as a result
over the last
call it five years how did you get from
30 million or so to 150 million what
does that take I mean I I mean I guess
the easy answer is like five years yeah
a lot of hard work yeah we know when you
come into a system you know like wow
there's a big pile of cash now the
expectation is I grow it meaningfully
yeah by the board how do you do you make
a five-year plan do you make a one-year
plan what's what is that growth what's
important in that growth phase because
that's that's a serious you know it's
one thing to get a copy at ten twenty
million yeah so whole nother thing to
get to nine figures yeah
scaling is scaling is hard now that
growth stages is is an interesting time
and I would say we did think about it
over okay for the next three to five
years where do we want to be and then
back walk yourself backwards from there
and I believed then and thankfully we
proved true I was like I believe this
has the ability to be a built to last
company one proxy for that is can we be
a public company withstand the scrutiny
of the public I be so disciplined in our
operations that we can execute as a
public entity if we can do that and we
have this grand vision that that that we
have and you know that can fuel us for
decades not just years then then we can
keep going and so we've looked at that
and then backed in and said okay well if
that's true boy we got a lot of work to
go do here and one of the challenges
you'd ask really like why was I brought
in you know make a CEO change if
everything's going perfectly that the
primary reason was our growth rate was
decelerating year over year which
happens you know kind of law every law
of large numbers right it's easier to
double when you're tiny
and and that kind of thing but but we
were decelerating to to a growth rate
that was in the 40s going to the 30s
that might have been going to the 20s
and we said we we can't have that we got
to arrest the deceleration and then
reaccelerating that was one of things
I'm probably most proud of that we were
able to accomplish in the couple few
years after I joined was we were able to
flatten the curve we call it the
SendGrid smile because the growth rate
went was going down you know we
flattened it and then we re accelerated
and it looks like a smiler that was it
spending money on marketing was it the
expanding the product offering was it
reconstituting the team wow you're good
you should be a CEO
you may choose not to me you just hit 30
you just hit the probably the three
biggest levers that we pulled okay in
fact we more than tripled our marketing
spend in that year what worked best and
most of it was I would say the principal
Channel was still was SEM there's a
reason Google is as big as they are got
it so that was that was a big part of it
we added a new product line so you
mentioned earlier you know we've been
known for the transactional email with
the developers we added a second product
line for the marketer uh and so now we
do compete head-to-head with MailChimp
and campaign mom what is that well folks
it's called marketing campaigns saturd
marketing campaigns and that's now a
meaningful business line for us I'm
trying again the last public number on
it was probably a twenty five million
dollar run rate business that doesn't
exist so ten fifteen percent already
yeah
and great and growing growing
meaningfully faster than the the overall
company average so that was a big part
of it and then we did reconstitute the
the executive team we there's our we
can't have our general counsel that is
the same from from the prior management
team and and then every other person was
new and we that was a difficult and long
process I hired a new executive leader
basically won a quarter for two years
Wow and then they would come in and
their domain experts and had seen scales
part of the prerequisite to hire them
was have you seen scale have you been at
a publicly traded company have you gone
through this phase before and they could
then come in and say we know what great
looks like and I would just you know
knowing what great looks like I think is
critical to taking your team there it's
just you know because they're leading
you now as opposed to you pushing people
who have never been there that's until I
go to the new world that's like I've
been to the new world I absolutely
I took the ship around we went around an
old horn they did we made it back it's
all good I've been there and I love
being the dumbest guy in the room in our
executive management team meetings where
I know my marketer or my product person
or my CFO will know has forgotten more
than I will ever know about how to do
their job in that function and I think
that was a big part of our success too
all right well you're back you decide
you keep bringing up going public as was
the mission there many Silicon Valley
startups are staying private
forever yeah I don't want to point out
any companies that I'm a large
meaningful shareholder in they've now in
year ten gonna be filed but you are zip
zip-zip got this company public and I
want to find out why you did that and
how you did it when we get back on this
week's herbs
[Music]